you
have you ever noticed that it's harder
to start pedaling your bicycle than it
is to ride at a constant speed or
wondered what causes your bicycle to
move or thought about why it goes
forward instead of backwards or side
when it's perhaps not and you wouldn't
be alone it wasn't until the 17th
century that Isaac Newton described the
fundamental laws of motion and we
understood the answer to these three
questions what Newton recognized was the
things tend to keep on doing what they
are already doing so when your bicycle
is stopped
it stays stopped and when it is going it
stays going objects in motion tend to
stay in motion and objects at rest and
to stay at rest that's Newton's first
law physicists call it the law of
inertia which is a fancy way of saying
that moving objects don't spontaneously
speed up slow down or change direction
it is this inertia that you must
overcome to get your bicycle moving now
you know that you have to overcome
inertia to get your bicycle moving but
what is it that allows you to overcome
it well the answer is explained by
Newton's second law in mathematical
terms Newton's second law says that
force is the product of mass times
acceleration to cause an object to
accelerate or speed up a force must be
applied the more force you apply the
quicker you accelerate and the more mass
your bicycle has and the more mass you
have - the more force you have to use to
accelerate at the same rate this is why
it would be really difficult to pedal a
10,000 pound bicycle and it is this
force which is applied by your legs
pushing down on the pedals it allows you
overcome Newton's law of inertia the
harder you push down on the pedals the
bigger the force and the quicker you
accelerate now on to the final question
when you do get your bike moving why
does it go forward according to Newton's
third law for every action there is an
equal and opposite reaction to
understand this think about what happens
when you drop a bouncy ball as the
bouncy ball hits the floor
it causes a downward force on the floor
this is the action the floor reacts by
pushing on the ball with the same force
but in the opposite direction upward
causing it to bounce back up to you
together the floor on the ball column is
called the action reaction pair when it
comes to your bicycle it is a little
more complicated as your bicycle wheels
spin clockwise the parts of each tire
touching the ground push backwards
against the earth the actions the ground
pushes forward with the same force
against each of your tires
the reactions since you have two bicycle
tires each one forms an action reaction
pair with the ground and since the earth
is really really really big compared to
your bicycle it barely moves from the
forest caused by your bicycle tires push
it backwards but you are propelled
forward